I gotta pick up my grandpa it's not
doing too well
my grandma's past Friday the road
thought the plan was their breakfast
here's that's your breakfast now let's
get in that giant labia you drove up in
and get the [ __ ] out of here so you're
alive now
your corporate lawyers awesome I get to
handle SEC compliance no [ __ ] LP
agreements LLC agreements you know what
I'd rather do what I'd rather let Queen
Latifah [ __ ] in my mouth from a [ __ ]
hot air balloon party some babies into
us we have a very important tea time
obviously I've got the bigger 3-wood
good maybe you can use it to hit your
balls right into my vagina oh I'm not
going to Daytona grandma's funeral was
yesterday
she told me on a deathbed you get back
out there again oh so that's what this
is all about you wanted me to drive you
down to Boca so I could be your wingman
I haven't had sex in 15 years I want to
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna throw
up the other one Spring Break no I can't
chug alcohol he developed like a gag
reflex you're chugging a beer not take
down a horse oh [ __ ] what's up Beach
we're just driving through she's not
right for you if you marry her you're
gonna be sleepwalking so the rest of
your life for one night stop worrying
about your wedding
[Music]
this is crap oh crap
yeah but just like a lot I just smoke
[Applause]
of those by pens I found a word there's
original in the pocket and I've been
sucking on it all morning whoops I guess
they just slipped off you guys
[Music]